foreign
[Music]
let's go
I did release a course on the jababa
London system with my good friend
Grandmaster olexander Bortnick the link
to that course will be in the
description to the next few YouTube
videos including this one and I'll
redirect you to the video where I kind
of advertise and preview the course more
specifically so in a couple of the
subsequent games I did want to introduce
the jababa London and show a couple of
cool lines from the course so this will
be sort of in parallel to the main
speedrun recommendation which is of
course 1e4 we had one jababa London game
already and in that game I did preview
the courses was a few games ago but
anyways let's focus on the task at hand
we are facing the move one G6 and when
you're a D4 player you have to be
flexible if you want to be a principled
serious opening player in the sense that
when you face moves like G6 or D6 or E6
there's no dispute that the best way to
quote called punish these openings is to
play principal chess right if you're a
London player you're a D4 C4 player
it you know if you want to really fight
for advantages in every game in
principled fashion then investing some
time studying certain D4 E4 openings is
very much worthwhile and this doesn't
necessarily make you an E4 player this
doesn't mean that you these openings
have nothing to do with the more
mainstream lines like the Sicilian and
the real Lopez and you can study them
from the white side even if you're not
too familiar with ideas inherent in one
E4 openings this I think is a big
misconception which is that let's say
you're a London player and say well if I
play E4 I have to know the ideas that
attend to one E4 openings not at all
this is its own thing and you can study
this as its own thing you don't have to
be an E4 player to uh to crush an
opening like the modern consistently
okay and hopefully this game is going to
show that I am an E4 player but I'm
gonna try to show that these openings
are pretty approachable and you can
learn them without investing 30 hours
into you know learning an entire
accessible course or learning a ton of
theory this is of course the modern and
we have a wealth of options against the
modern starting from this position where
we can develop either the Knight to F3
or the Knight to C3 I've also previously
played the move Pawn to C3 in a previous
Speed Run games in order to take this
bishop out of commission but let's play
principal chess
in this game let's go Knight C3
uh which is of course the main move and
it's also the most flexible move uh
because you reserve the ability to push
the pawn up to F4 that is the Austrian
attack which is the most principled way
of meeting the perk but we're right now
facing a different system this is called
the gurganizi system named after
Georgian Grandmaster bukhudi Guru
ganense and this has been around really
since the 50s and 60s Hikaru loves to
play this system with black and Blitz
Games because it's it's an easy system
to play and oftentimes the center gets
really locked up so if white is
unfamiliar with the main ideas you can
really get a problematic position
a White's main move in this position is
still to play F4 but that's not what
we're gonna do I'm going to introduce
you to a very practical system against
the gurganinsay which gives white a very
easy position to play Black can equalize
against this system with ultra precise
play but it's practical in the sense
that most players I think under 24 2300
will probably not be familiar with the
correct pathway and will not reproduce
it to uh to the most precise extent what
we do here is start with the move Bishop
to E3 you can also start with the move
F3 I think Bishop E3 is more flexible
right you want to reserve the pawn moves
and delay them until you absolutely have
to play them whereas you know that
Bishop E3 is a nice developing move as
it is black is not obliged to play D5
and I would Define the gurga ninsi as a
cross between the Karo Khan and the
modern right so black tries to get the
best of all worlds and the move Bishop
E3 is helpful even if black deviates and
goes D6 and transitions back into like a
perk setup Bishop on E3 is a very very
good piece whereas we're not totally
sure that we in fact want to put the
pawn in F3 but now that black has played
D5 we basically are playing the fantasy
variation my official recommendation
against the Karo Khan as you hopefully
know is the fantasy so if you strip away
these two minor pieces and this piece
you we actually just have a fantasy and
it's quite clear
uh that the moves Knight C3 and Bishop
E3 have not detracted from the effect
effectiveness of our setup to the
contrary that's actually where the
bishop often belongs in the fantasy and
the Knight of course is usually
developed to C3 as well so there's only
one move as far as I know that allows
black to fight for equality all other
moves give white an excellent position
and it's easy to lose this very very
quickly if you're not Ultra accurate
with black a lot of players just don't
have a good sense of where the pieces
belong here and one of the biggest draws
of the move F3 is that black experiences
problems with their Knight on G8 in the
gurgan it's a system you you might have
seen like Hikaru
and others bring the night out to age
six here this move is not sensible
because white plays Queen D2 the F5
square is protected that's the key
that's why we're delaying the move E5
meanwhile if black plays Knight F6 that
also walks into E5 and black has to lose
yet another Tempo Shifting the Knight
back toward a very awkward Square such
as D7 our opponent counter strikes in
the center I will admit that I'm not
familiar with this move and perhaps
neither is our opponent
but this is a move which
isn't Justified from a general principle
standpoint because we are the ones with
a lead in development black is blasting
open the center which should favor the
side that has more pieces developed in
this case it's us and I don't think that
we should overthink it right hey our
opponent wants to open up the center I
am absolutely game the one thing that
you should notice is that after Pawn
takes E5 which I think is what we're
gonna play I don't see the reason uh I
don't particularly uh see a compelling
reason to take the pawn on D5 we can do
it on on the next move what you should
notice though is after d takes e black
does not have the move d4 you should
make a mental note to yourself that
these pieces are unforkable squares but
D4 doesn't work because we have two
Defenders on that square and black has
only one attacker so I think the best
most flexible way to continue is first
and foremost to take on E5 you want to
open up the center I'm more than happy
to do that and if black recaptures with
a bishop I don't see a reason that we
can't just then take on D5 and hunt for
the extra Pawn
alternatively we could focus on quickly
developing Our Queen side with Queen D2
and long Castle
in order to exert more pressure on the
D5 Pawn that leads to some interesting
tactical complications Queen D2 here may
seem to be a blunder due to D4 but if
you look a little bit further in that
position we can castle queenside and
black can't move the d-pawn because the
Queen's gonna hang with Checkmate but
black can support the d-pawn by playing
C5 and I'm not totally convinced that
that's the way the way to go
I mean other than he takes D5 perhaps
there's like Bishop to D4 trying to get
the the dark squared Bishops off the
board and really underscore the the
weakness of the dark squares on the king
side but that just seems a little bit
too fancy I think that we should start
with the move e takes D5
and depending on how black responds
we will either try to solidify our extra
material or we will focus on getting our
King out of the center because you
should remember that when you play the
move F3 you make rather serious
weaknesses in your Center and on your
king side in particular the bishop on E3
loses its support why is that important
well if black plays Knight F6 and then
castles and puts a rook on E8 we're
gonna have to be really really careful
because that Bishop on E3 is going to
get caught in the crossfire and the last
thing that you want is a king stuck in
the center after you've played the move
F3 and after Black's gotten a rook to E8
so our biggest priority here apart from
making sure that this Pawn remains
healthy is perhaps an even bigger
priority is to go Queen D2 and long
castle and get the king to safety so
that we can focus on operating properly
on the king side hopefully that makes
sense okay Pawn takes D5 so this poses
us with a dilemma do not play Queen
takes D5 that drops the queen to Bishop
takes C3 because that is a check
we could play Knight takes D5 and in
response I presume the black wants to
play Bishop takes B2 but there's a move
I like even more than Knight takes D5
this Pawn is now an isolated Pawn
technically it's an iqp this is not the
usual iqp setups that we tend to get but
it's still an iqp structure
the pawn on D5 is a serious weakness so
the move I am very tempted to play is
still Queen to D2 and in contrast to
playing it here what's the chief
difference well after Queen D2 D4 long
Castle black doesn't have another Pawn
to defend D4 with and if black plays
there the move Knight to C6 who can tell
me a way in which we can indirectly
reinforce the pressure on the D4 Pawn I
think that move that resulting move is
super important and it's the move Bishop
F1 to B5 and the secondary point of that
move is that if black then takes on E3
we take on d8 and the Knight on C6 is
pinned so because of that line I think
Queen D2 it works out tactically and so
it just makes a lot more sense to me to
develop quickly rather than trying to
greedily capture the pawn and get into
tactical complications after Bishop
takes B2 maybe those complications favor
white I don't know but in this speedrun
we're trying to play Simple
straightforward chess when ever possible
so again the line that we had to
calculate is D4 long Castle
black can't take because the queen hangs
and Knight C6 is always met with Bishop
B5 okay our opponent develops himself 97
I think we continue with our plan we
long Castle anyway and we exert
additional pressure on the D5 Pawn
what you should note here is that our
advantage is not just based on the
weakness of the D5 font it's not like if
we don't win that pawn then the position
is equal we're also better from a
positional standpoint because we have
control of the square in front of the
pawn and as you know from previous
discussions of iqp structures that's
like the first thing that you should be
paying attention to who's got this
control of the square in front of the
isolated Queen Pawn if it's us then we
can put a knight on that square and
that's a pretty juicy night let alone
that in the modern and in the purits
White's main plan is to attack the king
side presumably Black's gonna castle at
some point and then we're gonna like
full send the pawns down the king side
the bishop on E5 is also really awkward
it can be targeted with a well-timed
bishop D4 so we can further soften up
the dark squares on the king side I
don't think that we should Rush
necessarily with Bishop D4 I think it's
a move we can really play whenever we
want to
so Bishop D4 is is a reasonable
alternative but the move that I really
like here I think the positional
approach
is either to play Bishop B5 check and
then Knight E2 but even better is I
think the immediate Knight to E2 quickly
aiming for D4 we're trying to plant a
knight on D4 just to make sure that this
Pawn remains immobilized
and the moment black Castle's kingside
which hopefully happens sooner rather
than later we're gonna send the pawn
down and try to blast open the H file
and just go for checkmate let's go
Knight T4 and establish the Knight on
this blockading Square
okay so what happens if there is a trade
well generally if there's an isolated
Queen Pawn trades favor the side that is
fighting against it and one way to think
about that is okay your opponent has
finite resources and finite minor pieces
if let's say two minor pieces are traded
then both of Black's remaining two minor
pieces are gonna have to be fully
focused on protecting the isolated Queen
Pawn that means black doesn't have the
resources to allocate to other things
like let's say defending the king okay
so the less pieces there are the more
valuable the remaining pieces become and
the less resources you have to spend on
like one particular task Queen to D7
okay so our opponent's going keeps the
tension I think we should also make a
move that kind of keeps the tension of
course we can already play H4 which is a
pretty helpful move I mean even if black
stays in the center opening up the H
file is still a pretty decent idea but I
don't think that we should commit to
anything in particular I think we should
continue accumulating the pressure in
whichever way we can there's two ways
that I see to do that the first is of
course the move Bishop B5 which I think
is probably on your radar the second is
just to play King to B1 which is a very
helpful move almost every single time
that you Castle queenside it's a good
idea to throw in the move King B1 just
because the king is safer on B1 than it
is on C1 I'll get into that in a little
bit more detail after the game which of
these two moves are we going to decide
on
it's hard to say
it's hard to say which move is better I
like Bishop B5 because it it pins the
Knight and it takes away the option of
of Knight takes D4 but I like King B1
because it's super flexible and I really
feel like the king is so much safer on
B1 than it is on C1
there's a concrete line I'm trying to
calculate after Bishop B5
and I can't tell if it's
good or bad for white
yeah
let's go Bishop B5 let's let's develop
the bishop let's develop the bishop and
obviously from a practical time
management standpoint you know these
dilemmas you normally don't want to
spend too much time on because chances
are right if you use your intuition
chances are this is not gonna decide the
game the decision that you make at this
point is not going to decide the game
because you know approximately
likelihood is that both of these moves
are about the same maybe one is a little
more accurate than the other but you
don't want to spend five six minutes
making these minuscule decisions right
you just have to have the executive
judgment to know when to spend a lot of
time on a critical moment and when there
are two moves that do similar things and
that are similar in nature
you don't want to spend most of the time
like more than you know maybe a minute
or two in a 15-minute game Castle's
Queen side that was on my radar I didn't
take this move too seriously because it
felt like Black's King is so flimsy with
the C file open and with uh Black's Pawn
cover already ruined this just felt
pretty Brazen but I guess it makes sense
I mean the king is safer here than it is
in the center
but it should be pointed out that we
don't have any obvious checkmating
procedure there's no way for us to
launch a direct attack against Black's
King I think our general strategy here
just has to be a couple of moves that
improve our position right we have to
accumulate and accumulate and eventually
something is going to be there I trust
in the center
let's start with the move King B1 let's
just get this out of the way so that we
don't have to think about it in the
future let's go King B1
and maybe we could have won a pawn now
that I'm looking at this we could have
maybe taken the bishop on E6 and then
played Bishop takes A7
but I don't know if I want to part ways
with this juicy Knight on D4 our
opponent does the same King B8 great
okay now let's continue playing
positionally and what playing
positionally often means not only just
like improving your position but also
trading off your opponent's strongest
piece or strongest pieces to me the
bishop on E5 is one of the pieces that
sort of it's a glue piece it holds
Black's position together it controls a
lot of critical squares so the moment
the king moves to B8 it's aligned with
the bishop there is a move I'm thinking
about and we're gonna play this move
because it has no downside not F4 not F4
now four merely chases the bishop back
to its home Square it does the same
thing on G7 that it does on E5 in fact I
would say it's even safer on G7 rather
than chasing the bishop away let's trade
the bishop off with Bishop to F4
so the tactics work out for us Knight
takes D4 is not even possible because
the Knight is pinned
and so is the bishop so black can't take
the Knight on D4
if black plays the move F6 and tries to
trade on his own terms then the bishop
on E6 loses its supporter and that
wasn't palatable either okay we traded
the Bishops we're making some progress
we've got a very pleasant position and
we just need to continue accumulating
the pressure right at this level a lot
of games are won exactly in this way you
just make improving moves and improving
moves and eventually of course you're
gonna have to transform your advantage
into something tangible but as long as
there are obvious improving moves you
want to continue making them and one of
them is just to bring the Rook to E1
this is a move everybody should see and
understand you're just bringing the Rook
to an open file nothing extraordinary
putting pressure on the bishop
and in these types of positions you have
to constantly keep generating and coming
up with new ways to improve your
position your opponent's turn is a great
time to do that because on your turn you
know you're thinking a little bit more
concretely about what to do so what are
some ways that we can accumulate even
further pressure on Black's position
well I was going to say queen to F6 but
we're faced with a new challenge Queen 2
D6 okay so let me think about this for
for a hot second I think we have some
tactics I think we have a perfect
opportunity to take the positional
advantage and transform it into
something more tactical this is an
advanced concept this is an advanced
procedure I'm not going to pretend that
this is Elementary it's not
how did I find this well one of the
things I noticed is that after the queen
trade there is an alignment of the Rooks
okay everybody should see this The Rook
on T1 and The Rook on T6 are on open
files The Rook on D6 is also undefended
so we have a procedure that first and
foremost opens up the D file so first
and foremost we take the bishop on E6
very importantly this move defends the
queen right otherwise we would just be
blundering the queen now from a
positional standpoint this is a
counterproductive move because we're
actually rectifying Black's Pawn
structure on in the center but what
we're actually doing is we're Shifting
the focus from the D file to the e-file
you can think of this as creating a new
weakness shifting Black's main weakness
from D5 to E6 which is now an isolated
pawn and it's targeted by the white Rook
now we trade Queens to get blackstroke
onto the most exposed Square possible
and hopefully you see where this is
going the Rooks are staring at each
other
the pawn on E6 is weak it's defended
only by The Rook on D6 and The crucial
move is Knight to E4 hitting the Rook
using tactics to force the Rook back to
either D7 or d8 and then the final step
is going to be to launch a frontal
attack on the pawn on E6 there's more
tactics that make this work if black
plays Rook to d8 you can't play Rook
takes C6 The Rook can't jump over the
Knight and the Knight is also hanging
now that the Rook is on a defended score
where do we go with the Knight you need
to be very accurate here you need to be
very very accurate here if you play the
tempting Knight to C5 some of you might
be thinking of this move black can
actually push the pawn to E5 remember
that is a way that your opponent can
defend a pawn that's attacked more than
once and defended zero times you can
actually push the pawn and put it on a
new square no you need to go Knight to
G5 because you need to pose a double
attack this is a double attack it's a
double attack in the literal sense we're
attacking the pawn twice but it's also a
double attack in the more classic sense
because we're posing a second threat
we're threatening Knight F7 forking the
Rooks and black
presumably is going to defend the F7
square or move one of the Rooks and then
we're gonna win the pawn on E6 and once
the pawn on E6 collapses
likely so will the pawn on T5 that pawn
is going to lose its supporter and we're
gonna go after that pawn next so we're
gonna try to win in the end two Pawns in
the end game and I'll expand a little
bit on how exactly I found this idea
after the game I largely this was
pattern recognition it's not like I
actually went through you know five
minute logical process and made
observations I saw this kind of
instinctively but this is what I try to
do in the speed run to kind of translate
my subconscious thoughts into a
conscious series of steps that you can
follow to find a similar idea in your
game
all right so I'm assuming our opponent
is going to move one of the Rooks
somewhere
yeah the fact that our opponent is
investing like
four or five minutes now in this move
tells us all we need to know Rook see
here that's a good move I think that's
the best move it's the Lesser evil now
we need to quickly decide what are we
going to take on E6 with it's not a
given that we take with a knife that's
probably the more natural move to most
of us but Rook takes C6 a case could be
a serious case could be made for taking
on E6 with the rook in the sense that it
keeps the immediate pressure on the
Knight on E7 and it does threaten to win
a second Pawn we're actually threatening
there to take on C6 Force the Knight to
recapture and then to take the pawn on
D5 I don't really want to part ways with
my Bishop if I can help it but it will
be worth paying that price for a second
Pawn what worries me slightly after Rook
takes C6 is a weird move like Knight F5
and then the other night is threatening
to jump into D4 there's like Fork ideas
and in the interest of time I'm also
trying to play in a way that corresponds
with the amount of time we have left
Knight takes E6 is just a simpler move
to handle
right generally in the end game you want
your Rooks operating from a distance you
don't want them on the front lines
because they start you know what I'm
talking about right when you have a rook
that's battling minor pieces at Close
Quarters uh I have a million examples of
this there's more tactics there are more
forks and you run the risk of you know
walking into something like an ill-timed
Knight D4 what about Knight F7 Knight F7
is
reasonable but I didn't see the point of
that okay A6 where does our Bishop go
well our main priority is to attack the
D5 Pawn the moment you tell this to
yourself the move should become very
obvious you have to play Bishop A4
because the bishop can later drop back
to B3 and exert direct pressure on D5
yeah Bishop A4 Bishop B3 is just El
Clasico kind of maneuver
what's great about the placement of the
Knight on E6 is that it's also
controlling the d8 square so on top of
everything else the black is
experiencing he can't put a rook on d8
the knights are totally immobilized as
well we're attacking D5 so the other
Knight can't move the knight from C6 can
move where will it go
it's mobility in the center is greatly
restricted
a black can barely move here you might
be sitting there with the white pieces
thinking man like I don't know if I'll
be able to convert this I'm getting
nervous but if you put yourself in your
opponent's shoes black literally is just
like out of moves
so however nervous you might feel it's
generally going to be infinitely more
difficult to be your opponent in these
types of situations than it is to be the
side that converts the advantage
another good move to to just throw in if
we have the time and we certainly have
the time
not because black has no counter plays
is just to get make some lufts we can do
that with the move C3 which kills two
birds with one stone it also fully
immobilizes the D5 Pawn making sure that
D4 isn't gonna happen it's harder to
shoot at a moving Target or of course we
can play the more straightforward A3 and
if we had like 30 seconds at this point
I would definitely play A3 right the
less time you have the more you have to
insure yourself against the possibility
of some freak tactic that you might not
have the time to see so if this was a
bullet game I would definitely be
playing A3 on the next move
now how do I know that we should play a
move like A3 well it's all about
whether or not your opponent has counter
play right does your opponent have a
clear path that he can follow in order
to generate counter play if the answer
is yes then you're generally in a bit of
a bit more of a hurry here the answer is
no because black is no squares for any
of their pieces Bishop back to B3
okay that's where we want it to go
anyway but there was nothing better
rookie it is a good move that's a tricky
move because
if we take on D5
then black will recapture with the
Knight we take with the rook and our
Knight on E6 there is
a little bit awkward right because it's
pinned to The Rook on E1 that's going to
lose its Defender so I don't want
anything
to have to do with Bishop takes D5
there's no rush that pawn isn't going
anywhere at all so let's focus on
improving our position such that when we
take the pawn we won't have to deal with
the Fallout and we won't have to rely on
tactics to get our Knight out of E6
the move that I mentioned earlier I
think it's a perfect time to play it
let's go C3
wait actually let me think about this
for a second because C3 maybe he's got
Knight A5 oh but then we've got Knight
G7 that's beautiful C3
yeah I love the move C3 because
another thing to notice and you notice
these things by avoiding tunnel vision
right it's easy to tunnel in on the D5
plan and forget that there are other
tactics that could have nothing to do
with the pawn on C5 anytime there's
contact between pieces you have to
notice that the Rook on E1 is not making
direct contact with the Knight on E7 but
it could be making direct contact after
a certain something moves so we're just
going to take on B4 and I played that
move quickly to lure my opponent into
recapturing quickly
which I think he might have smelled a
rat but at this point it's too late no
he didn't and by not tunnel visioning
you are going to be able to find a move
that wins on the spot now the Knight on
E7 is what we call a type 2 undefended
piece it's only protected by one other
piece if you can dislodge that Rook from
E8 well then likely you're going to win
the Knight on E7 because the Rook can't
maintain contact with the Knight there's
no ninth rank what's the move
it's not Bishop A4 I tricked you some of
you might say ah it's Bishop A4 no
because then The Rook moves and the
white Rook can't jump over the Knight
you need to do two things at once
you need to move the Knight away and
attack The Rook can you do that you
absolutely can and that's the move
Knight G7 fianchettoing the Knight
and that ends the game that ends the
game
yeah Knight G7 is is one of those like
geometric moves that can be hard to spot
because your brain doesn't often
associate like the G7 Square for your
opponent with like a knight being there
but the more concrete you're thinking
the more
specifically
you formulate questions to yourself the
likelier it is that you may that you
see a relatively unorthodox tactic
and obviously like making observations
does not guarantee that you will find a
tactic it raises the probability that
you see stuff and it raises the amount
of things that that you see so by not
tunneling in on the D5 fund we were able
to find this move if we had tunneled in
on the D5 Pawn we would have certainly
played the move A3 that that is the move
I would play if I was just obsessed with
winning the spawn and say oh well let's
get the night out of B4 and then let's
take the pawn obviously 927 is quite a
bit sexier let's take the rook and
what's ironic is that now the second
idea comes into play this is awesome
first we win one Rook by playing Knight
G7 now we can try to win the second one
by playing the move that some of you
wanted to play initially now it's time
for Bishop to A4 I love that the bishop
dropped back to B3 in order to attack D5
and now moves up again to at A4
where it encounters greener pastures the
game is over if Black Blocks with Knight
C6 we of course simply take the Knight
and then we take on E8 and the opening
experiment was a success
so as we get into the analysis once
again
uh the link to my jababa London course
is going to be in the description of
this video as is going to be the link to
a preview video that tells you all you
need to know about the course
but in this game it was not meant to be
and we deviated on move one of course
after D4 black is not obliged to play
the moves D5 or Knight F6 that's what
you're gonna face 90 of the time but you
have to have responses prepared against
some of the other moves in this position
I'm talking F5 E6 B6 and you can learn
most of those you know in like a couple
of well-allocated days
the jababa London itself happens after
Knight F6 Knight C3 D5 and Bishop F4
this is the starting position of the
chorus okay so in this game we faced the
move G6 this is of course the modern
defense and I would call this the close
sibling of the pier it's the Pirates or
the perk as some of us call it is
D6 of course white plays generally E4
Knight F6 Knight C3 and G6 the modern is
I think call that because black delays
the development of the Knight and this
is a somewhat cageier version of the
periods you might say well what's the
utility of delaying the move Knight F6
well by delaying this move black opens
up more possibilities for themselves so
for example after E4 Bishop G7 Knight C3
okay our opponent played the gurganinsay
that's one thing you can't really do
with appearance because you already have
a Pawn on D6 so this is one thing
another very common continuation that's
unique to the modern after D6 I was
planning to play F4 and go into the
Austrian attack here you can transpose
into the periods of Knight F6 but you
can also play uh a move that I think is
sometimes known as Tigers modern named
after a Swedish Jam tiger Hill are
person if you're interested in exploring
this line from Black's perspective he
wrote a book called tigers modern that
I've heard really good things about so
this is a serious opening for black the
reason I don't recommend it at all to
anybody under say 2200 is because you
need to know reams of opening Theory and
you need to know it in order to avoid
getting completely crushed so this
opening guarantees essentially that you
will have winning chances but it also
guarantees that you have quite a few
losing chances so I won't talk about
Asics here because we have plenty to
discuss uh in the context of the gurga
nid say so C6 enters the gurgaensei I
actually am curious whether we were
going to say was the first player to
play the move C6 I'm going to bet no
and I'm going to ask you guys a trivia
question
and let's say the question is as follows
do we think that this position occurred
for the first time before 1900 or after
1900. I have a guess but I'm I'm curious
what people think
when did this position first occur in
tournament practice and if you're
watching on YouTube you can
try to make a guess
yeah we're pretty much split down the
middle I'm going to guess after I'm
going to guess
1940. I'm gonna guess 1940. let's see
and the answer is 1953 and oh and this
is cool it was first played by generic
kasparian who was an international
master from Armenia and he's more well
known as a study composer he's a super
famous study composer and studies are
invented chess positions that serve as
really beautiful chess puzzles
first person to play this gurga nid say
I see his name but he was maybe like the
10th or 11th player to play this move in
1968 uh 15 years later Igor zaitsev was
the third person to play this he was
Anatoly karpov's second and one of his
most loyal assistants also a Grandmaster
so it's really interesting to see how
these openings start to acquire
popularity
anyways the main line of course is still
to play F4 black responds with D5 and
you might look at this and say well this
looks like Black's Bishop is terrible
but what black has accomplished by
playing this kind of cross between the
modern
and the Karo Khan is that black has
carved out these light squares on the
king side you guys should see how well
first of all the F5 Square the G4 Square
the E4 square there's a kind of a
complex of weak light squares and black
can Orient his play around those light
squares that is why you see black
playing H5 this is the main move it is
intended to prevent G4 and to secure the
F5 Square for the bishop if you play
Bishop F5 immediately you walk right
into G4 after H5 white generally
responds with Knight F3 and the Black
Knight is developed to H6 if you
understand the high level approach these
moves should not be a mystery to the
Knight where is it going well it's going
to one of these weak light squares and
if white is not well versed in this
structure white can get a really bad
position really fast what's an example
of that well a lot of people they play
the move H3 because they kind of want to
prepare G4 if you play this move
prematurely you're actually creating
even more weaknesses on the king side
because you can't easily play G4 of of
course here no hear The Rook hangs on H1
but if you don't play G4 if you make you
know a random developing move who can
tell me a typical move you see this
often in the gurganensei that
essentially prevents G4 once and for all
and this is a worthy move to know this
also occurs very often in the king's
Indian this exact idea is common in the
king's Indian from black side I'm
talking about the move H4
how does this permanently prevent G4
well obviously black has on passant and
in order to start surrounding this Pawn
white has to give away the light squared
Bishop now these squares are even weaker
and black has the bishop pair so you can
definitely explore some of the gergen
and say on your own and from a computer
standpoint if you turn on the engine the
engine most of the time depending on
which engine stockfish I think does
recommend the move F4 and white is
better if white handles this position
very accurately white is definitely
better but in this game I wanted to
choose something a little bit more
practical let me show you how this is
similar to The King's Indian in the
king's Indian in many lines
you get a situation D6 let's go down uh
the protrusion variation which is an
early D5
just as an example
so you often get this type of situation
the Knight gets to see five and it
exerts pressure on e4 so now you play A5
you've probably seen me do this a
million times you do that to prepare to
prevent B4 and a lot of players who are
newer to the king's Indian from the
white side they tend to play the move A3
thinking well I'm just gonna play B4 in
one Fell Swoop and of course you'll run
into A4 this is a very nasty
construction because white can basically
never play the move before and on top of
that black gets a really nice Outpost
for the Knight and then black can
solidify the A4 Pawn with the move
Bishop to D7 okay so again and again
as you get to a higher level as you gain
rating this is worthwhile to do like to
see similarities between openings that
you play and openings that you see in
high level chess that way you build a
more comprehensive picture of Chess as a
whole and the higher rated you are the
wider and broader your chess education
and your chest knowledge has to be
because you're going to get more and
more diverse types of positions out of
the opening because people are going to
be playing different stuff they're going
to know it and so it's it pays to to be
familiar with different types of
structures and different types of ideas
across many openings Okay so
so after C6 we decided on Bishop E3 and
we decide to build up the pawn chain
with the move F3 so a little bit of
theoretical overview the most popular
move in this position
for black is D takes E4 this I believe
is not the correct move it's the move I
think that you will face very very often
and after Pawn takes E4 uh it is common
for black to counter strike in the
center with E5 but after E5 black is
clearly worse white takes on E5
and generally black trades Queens here
if black takes on E5 right away well
this is even worse version uh because
here you can trade Queens on your own
and get your night out and you just get
an overwhelming development advantage in
this type of position I mean just look
at this bishop C4 Castle Queen side it's
already plus three this is out of the
question so most of the time black takes
the Queen White takes back and here I've
had this position against Hikaru quite a
few times Bishop takes E5 is a mistake
because it walks right into Knight F3 10
games in the database and black is in
massive massive trouble Bishop G7 Bishop
comes out to C4 and there's tactics
Galore on all sides of the board after
something like Knight D7 white castles
look at the pressure on the f file here
black can't get their pieces out at all
Knight gf6 walks into E5
23-42 had this position in 2009 Knight
G4
and now after Bishop to D4 that's how
the game continued
let me see how the game continued yeah
oh white didn't play E5 in the game why
I didn't play E5 this position is
completely and utterly lost for black if
black plays Knight takes C5 then you can
play 95 Bishop E5 and who can spot the
killer blow in this position why does a
move that ends the game immediately this
is a trick question ladies and gentlemen
so take a little bit of time here be
careful be careful
foreign
question should lead you to suspect that
rookie one is not the best move black
defends the Knight with F6 white is
still winning but more accurate is
Bishop takes F7 check simple tactics
takes takes Rogue G8 and white ends the
game with rookie one winning all of
Black's pieces if black plays King E7
this is literally Checkmate hello
so so Bishop takes E5 just gives white
this overwhelming lead in development
instead the best move is Knight t7
Hikaru has has played this move he's
also played Bishop E5 against me and one
pretty sure so here there is a very
important concept A Move That forces
black to ruin his own structure as well
this is incredibly common whenever you
have a pawn that is condemned this Pawn
is condemned right you're gonna lose it
anyway well you don't give it away
without a fight you don't give it away
without forcing some concessions uh and
so the best move here is
uh is to play E6 F takes E6 and
according to my analysis uh White just
needs to play solid positional chess
it's plus over minus it's like 0.8 uh in
favor of white here and it's not
surprising white is better development
the pawn and E6 is much weaker than its
counterpart and if black just precedes
nonchalantly you're gonna plant the dark
Squad Bishop on D4 in order to
neutralize its counterpart on G7 let's
say black I don't know let's say black
castles of course Bishop C4 of course
Knight G5 the position plays itself and
I don't say that lightly white Scott
fantastic chances in a position like
this
what else is there so in this position I
think that's basically it I mean black
can also Play Bishop to E6 in order to
try to prevent white from uh playing
Pawn to E6 but here of course you don't
give away the pawn
here the loss of a Tempo means that
white will cling to this Pawn on E5
which makes it very difficult for black
to develop their knight uh to a good
spot remember that H6 is almost always
met here with the move H4 you want to
prevent uh King side expansion with G5
so this is one of the biggest draws of
this line a lot of people go into this
end game and it's just virtually
unplayable from a practical standpoint
Knight to F6 is the other move that you
should be familiar with uh in this
position white of course responds with
uh a developing move of our own and if
black plays Knight to G4 as scary as
this move looks it's it's really not a
big deal
and okay there's many things that you
can do here I like the simple Bishop up
to F4
and generally black again plays the move
E5 if black just continues to develop
well you're gonna play H3 you're gonna
bring your queen up to D2 and I mean
look at White's incredible Center and
White's attacking prospects on the king
side are delicious so
I'm seeing a game in the database that
went B5
just a moment I'm seeing a game that
went B5 and white can play something
like the engine likes E5 Knight to D5
and Bishop to H6 getting rid of black
Stark Square Bishops and you're gonna
play H4 H5 HG and there will be hell to
pay for black so this is very one-sided
after Bishop F4 black should play E5 and
here we reach a slightly better version
of this end game for black but white is
still better takes takes Knight to D7 we
play E6 F take C6 and you can play a
move like Bishop 2 E2 okay and after
black castles the engine actually likes
keeping this bishop on this diagonal
because there are some important squares
on it you don't want to go Bishop G3 and
walk into Knight E3 right so you want to
keep the bishop here you're gonna Castle
you're gonna enjoy your life in an end
game like this
so that's an overview of Pawn takes E4
other moves aren't really worth talking
about other than the best move which is
Queen to B6
I'll get to it in a moment if black
plays Knight F6 you get like a a much
improved version of the gurga Nancy
because here the Knight can't easily get
to F5 so this position just sucks for
black and you don't have to play F4 but
I think this makes sense and then you're
gonna go Knight F3 and potentially
you're just gonna go like H4 and blast
through on on the king side
so the best move and the move that not a
lot of people know at an intermediate
level is Queen to B6
I had a game here a classical game
against Alex Lenderman who's a top
American GM in 2011 which I managed to
win
and the best move for white is just to
ignore the threat on B2 and play the
move Queen to D2
black has to know to accept the
sacrifice it's not really a sacrifice
because you're going to win the pawn
back but to really as a sales pitch for
this line I want to show you the start
of my game against Letterman to show you
how difficult it is to handle this type
of position for black let me find the
game of the database oh no I'm sorry it
was slightly different it was E4 G6 D4
Bishop G7 Knight C3 C6 Bishop E3 and he
immediately played the move Queen B6 and
this is a different version I played
Queen D2 so I was almost right takes
Rook B1 Queen A3 Knight F3 and this
position is an improved version for
white because black can't play D5
anymore that square is now covered twice
but watch what happened in Slenderman
game he played the move B5 in order to
prevent the Bishop from coming out to C4
who can tell me how I punished this his
lack of development here
and there's a beautiful detail a really
nice move that would have finished the
game immediately that I missed
here the move like plays itself like you
just can't resist of course it's Bishop
B5 and Letterman saw this he accepts my
Bishop here I started to get very
excited and this is the position that he
was aiming for I missed the best move I
played Knight C7 and after King d8 we
had total incomplete chaos white however
is winning on the spot with an
incredible move this is really beautiful
let's see if anybody can find it pause
the video if you're on YouTube maybe
take a good like three to five minutes
here if you really want to work your
Tactical brain not castles that's a
little slow
castles is slow
no it's not castles if you see if you
Castle then black will defend the C7
square with Knight A6 and you say oh I
trap the queen you don't the queen has
C4
and that's a hint C4 is the only
evacuation square that the queen has you
got it sardine you earned a sub
or everybody who answered is this up
Queen to C3 ends the game immediately
because if black takes with check you
bring the king up black loses the queen
because if he takes you get checkmated
on C8 now this is a very high level move
if black plays Knight to A6 in order to
defend the bishop you win the game with
the secondary idea Rook to A1 there's no
more C4 square and queen E6 runs into
Rook takes a six and black loses
everything actually black loses the
queen because of Knight C7 now the game
could last a little bit longer because
black has a rook and a piece for the
queen but it's like plus six obviously
White's just crushing
so this just gives you a sense of how
difficult these positions are to play
but unfortunately we're talking here
about a slightly different version here
with the pawn on D5 it's improved
but after Queen takes B2 Rook B1 Queen
A3 actually I was wrong
um yeah because in the Letterman game my
knight was on F3 that's the main reason
this is an improved version for black
here you play e takes D5 and I still
maintain I still maintain that this is a
much easier position to play for white
but it is equal and it's equal if black
knows the move Knight to F6 first of all
uh you bring
the bishop out I'm pretty sure according
to what I looked at no you play D takes
C6 and here black has to know another
move Knight takes C6 is a bad move
because of D5 and white gets a big
initiative you have to know the move BC
Which is far from intuitive I think
white develops the bishop to D3 castles
Knight G2 white is a very compact
position and again engine gives equal
but black has to know more engine moves
like Bishop to A6 and finally this
position is equal for
obvious reasons I mean black is good
well-placed pieces but so does white so
it's one of those things if your
opponent knows all of these moves if you
watch this video Kudos you know take
your hat off sometimes you just have to
admit that your opponent knows
everything but I don't think that you're
gonna face this sequence of moves all
that often you're gonna face Knight F6
or Pawn takes E4 some people are gonna
probably go Knight H6 which is really
dumb because of Queen D2 sending the
Knight right back to G8
okay so finally we get to our opponent's
move which is nothing to sneeze at I
mean E5 is a legitimate alternative
but I'm pretty sure that it hands over a
big initiative after and a big Advantage
after Pawn takes C5 okay so Bishop takes
C5 and we played the move e takes D5
which is normal according to the
computer the computer also likes the
immediate Bishop to D4 which came across
our radar I mean this is not an engine
move it's a pretty obvious idea
um and according to the computer forcing
this bishop off the board would give
white a big Advantage like plus 1.5 and
in my move it's around plus point eight
so it's not a mistake but Bishop D4 is
even more accurate what was I worried
about here I thought the black would go
here
but apparently after you trade you just
go Queen D2 and White's huge development
Advantage gives him just an overwhelming
position wherever black goes you're now
gonna Castle ah and black can't take on
e4 because of the because of the main
and if black castles then you say thank
you very much for the pawn take Stakes
takes and when is much better
so Bishop D4 would have been best but
instead we played he takes D5 which I
think is perfectly suitable
C takes D5 and of course we bring our
Queen up to uh D2 and white has a small
ish but very stable advantage and most
importantly this is a much easier
position uh to play for white
so hopefully that overview was sensible
and you understood all of the main ideas
so here we develop our pieces 97 castles
Bishop E6 I think this is uh quite
normal and obvious without uh without
without commentary the next interesting
moment really occurred after we played
Knight D4 uh blackplayed Queen D7 and I
feel like black embarks fundamentally on
the wrong plan I just feel like castling
Queen side here opens black up to so
many problems in the center and on the
queen side I would go so far as to say
that at a title player level castling
queenside might be close to the decisive
mistake what would I do instead here for
black well the move that concerned me
the most was actually a very simple
approach where black trades off all the
pieces that he can and castles kingside
and I did mention during the game that
peace trades favor the side that plays
against the iqp well yes but here black
has bigger fish to fry in particular
black wants to avoid getting checkmate
did and the Queen on D4 is not a good
blockader right by trading you've
essentially lured the queen onto D4
where it can be susceptible to of course
the move Knight F5 or to the move Knight
C6 and if white plays H4 black and play
Knight C6 and if we play Queen D2 black
can push D4 and it's quite clear the
black has generated serious counter play
against the queen side according to the
engine white is still quite a bit better
with Knight E4
because Queen D5 runs into the fork and
Bishop takes A2 is uh very dubious on
account of the typical uh B3
the white is still better
uh but blue Exposition remains quite
playable maybe this is a better option
after Queen D2 D4 here this comes with
far greater effect because the Knight
can get into E3
so something like this I think would
have given black a defensible position
after Queen D7 Bishop B5 long castle and
King B1
is maybe less to the point than a move
like Rook H E1 but I just wanted to
illustrate how pleasant positions like
this are to play and how you really just
need to kind of enjoy positions like
this and moves like King B1 signify that
you're not in any massive hurry to do
something crazy just make these
improving moves and you will notice how
your opponent often just collapses on
their own
King B8 and now a very important move
Bishop F4 trading off our opponent's
strongest piece was this the only move
no
probably the computer would prefer
something more straightforward like Rook
HD1 but it's a
very sensible move because we are
leaving black with a terrible Bishop on
E6 that's essentially just a big Pawn so
Bishop F4 Queen F4 and I think another
mistake uh is the move King A8 I I think
Queen C7 uh should have been preferred
essentially forcing our hand our
opponent gave us too many free moves he
let us bring all our pieces to Great
squares I mean it's no surprise then
that we had a game-winning tactic
literally all of our pieces are located
on perfect squares when that is the case
you just automatically need to search
for tactics if you're looking at your
position you're saying wait everything
is placed perfectly it's all staring at
crucial files and weaknesses you better
start looking for tactics
okay so Queen C7 I think was Black's
last chance to attain a defensible
position I might even have taken on C7
and taken on C6 something like this the
engine actually likes this
because after BC Rook HD1 again black is
under tremendous pressure on the e-file
and Rook to D6 is possible but now we
can Target the square on C5
whenever you have a structure that
involves hanging pawns on C6 and D5 your
sort of traditional textbook plan
involves what I call the Rubinstein
maneuver
and I've named it after Akiba Rubinstein
who demonstrated a perfect way to play
against this Pawn chain C6 and D5 what
idea am I talking about what Square are
we trying to occupy and with what piece
and for what purpose but if you want you
can just name the square
so don't touch the Knight on D4 it's
perfect the Knight on D4 is serving an
important purpose but the other night is
unemployed and we want to go Knight A4
and Knight C5 by occupying the second
block hitting Square we're completely
immobilizing this Pawn chain it's the
same Principle as occupying the D4 or D5
Square when one side has an iqp here is
a very quick run through
of the Rubinstein game that I'm talking
about
thing is these two players Rubenstein
and his opponent was York salve
who was uh one of the top players of
that time
yeah basically what happened in this
game
was a situation in which black got that
structure okay
and white did exactly what we just
discussed why it brings his pieces out
Knight A4 there it is and white piles up
on the C5 square with everything that
he's got Rook C1
Bishop C5 there it is
and everything is all about the C5
Square by keeping this Square under
control you're ensuring that C6 remains
a weakness forever watch what Rubenstein
does Bishop F1 E3 get the Knight to C5
block a the square bring the Rook to C2
B4 fully ensconcing The Rook on C5 and
eventually Rubenstein has some tactics
the rule applies here as well in this
position all of rubenstein's pieces are
in perfect squares the bishop The Rook
the Queen the other rook and guess what
there is a tactic that involves Rook
takes C6 and queen takes A7 at one
moment I'll invest more time in this
game because there's a lot to talk about
but I'm uh for those watching on YouTube
this has been a six hour stream and I'm
I'm basically exhausted already so I'm
gonna leave that for another occasion
and the final thing to discuss is how
exactly we saw 96 and 94 because after
this move I think everything was
incredibly straightforward once we win
the spawn the game is over let's be real
but how whatever you find moves like
this well one piece of advice is
everything is placed perfectly look for
tactics but the other things I mentioned
during the game there's contact on the D
file between the Rooks any contact
between heavy pieces is automatically a
source of tactics particularly because
the Rook on D6 is undefended the other
thing to remember is that um
is that is that you should not get
fixated on
on maintaining one particular Pawn
structure you should not be afraid to to
alter the pawn structure your opponent
has in order to shift the the object of
attack from one file to another and this
is the case here you have just have to
consider this capture because it's
obvious that you want to go after one of
Black's Pawns so seeing these two moves
is just a matter of you know calculating
the stuff that you're supposed to
calculate and then seeing Knight E4 is a
matter of being aware of the placement
of the Rooks the fact that the Rook on
D6 is undefended and ultimately 94
should come to mind right more often
than not which is not to say you're
going to see all of these moves but when
you solve and you go through this
process you're just trying to raise the
probability that you find certain things
Knight G5 Knight takes C6 and the rest I
think is very evident without without
commentary we got our Bishop back to B3
to attack D5 we played the very patient
move C3 and then we pounced on the
opportunity to win the 997 we didn't
Tunnel Vision on the D5 Pawn this by the
way I thought was a little bit more
messy because the Knight on E6 is pinned
to The Rook the engine indicates that
it's completely winning with rookie four
I didn't see this move but why why
bother when we can make a patient move
that keeps all of our advantages and uh
reserves the right to take on D5
whenever we want to
yeah some of you were asking about
Bishop takes D5 so again hopefully my
the object of My worry is obvious I also
for some reason was a little concerned
about Knight d8 of course I missed from
a distance that you have Knight C7 check
which is a simple discovered attack but
if I had seen Rook to E4 I would have
probably gone for this because this is
like concretely unbeatable black can't
even go rookie eight because again
there's Knight C7 again
and you win The Rook in a different way
so this is just two puns up also from
the corner of my eye
I thought maybe this move is going to be
annoying but you can just drop the Rook
back to D2 and then again you can play
rookie four on the next move
all right guys I think everything is
clear so what we had was a summary of
the theory after F3 remember Queen B6 is
the best move still doesn't solve all of
flex problems E5 happened in the game d
takes E4 is what I spent the most time
on
then we could have played Bishop D4 in
this position to immediately Target
Black's strongest piece this was a sub
theme of the game targeting her
opponent's strongest pieces the other
main thing was patience right this game
was all about patience it started here
where Knight takes D5 super impatient
move would allow either a big lead in
development or chaos after Bishop takes
B2 neither of which we want so we
patiently develop our Queen side then
patience in this part of the game where
we just bring our pieces and put them on
good squares because we have the time to
do that trading off your opponent's
strongest piece
Rook HD1 and then tactical awareness at
the right moments right understanding
that when everything is well placed
you're likely to have some way to
convert the positional Advantage into
something more tactical that's what I
was able to do by bringing the Knight to
G5 winning the pawn and the technical
phase of the game was very
straightforward thanks for hanging out
everybody
[Music]